you know everyone has their own reasons
for tattoos I like it you might not like
it but for me it's I would do it all
over again okay I got my first tattoo
right before the 2012 Olympics it's
actually inside my arm it was kind of
special to me since it was actually in
London my hometown I actually got them
from London to London on top of it so
that was kind of the first one and it's
been a long road since I think
especially someone that's also in my
sport it's very rare to see a tattoo I
think for me it's cool to kind of see me
from the outside perspective I kind of
looked like everyone else until
obviously take up my mask and then I
kind of take off my jacket and then I'm
just a whole different person
this is I'm kind of what I lived my life
by which means traitor legacy not a
moment and actually I don't think my mom
sees this actually it's in the Malawian
flag which is where she was born so you
go mom this is actually the Statue of
Liberty but it's kind of drawn in a
section up kind of way this is actually
the first thing I saw when I moved to
America on the plane back in London you
don't really know what that is Oh
someone's kind of holding something out
that's pretty cool
moving to kind of changed my life that's
kind of one reason why I got that and
then on the back side of it you have my
actual version of such as IV which is
Big Ben so you know what conflicted
about my roots I'm gonna get Big Ben was
just kind of an iconic piece of pretty
charted Kevin Kim did a sick job with
this one made it super real something I
was like okay this bad boy you can tell
what this is the Kunduz worked perfectly
together they kind of fitted in
perfectly and then I was done with that
and I was okay cool I'm done and then I
lied to myself again and then I got all
this one which means the mind is
everything I got that as well and then
virtually I need to get on this side so
then I got you must know how to lose
before you can learn how to win that one
down here which kind of
a little bit this is all I won't touch I
thought about it I worked you hard my
abs